LISA JACKSON: Because you
came here for an education.
And as the years
go by, you're going
to realize that you
absolutely got one.
Maybe no education is
important as learning
that being part of a diverse
community takes work.
And it takes practice.
And give and take on both sides,
and compassion for each other,
above all.
SANJEEV KULKARNI: The process
of mastering a discipline
and contributing something
new to a body of knowledge
with a deep focus is, in fact,
broadening and liberating.
It enables one to pursue
new directions, new fields,
or entirely new endeavors, with
the abilities and confidence
not just to succeed,
but to excel.
Congratulations on
your accomplishments.
MISHA SEMENOV: Even as we
celebrate our accomplishments
here, we must begin a lifelong
journey of applying our
chustvitelnost, our
child-like openness
to our everyday
interactions-- sharing
the gifts we have been
given with others,
with those who are forced
to grow up too soon.
With those who helped
make possible our standing
here today.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: My
colleagues and I on the faculty
and the administration, my
fellow alumni and trustees
hope you carry the spirit
of Princeton into the world.
And we look forward to
welcoming you back to Princeton
whenever you return.
We feel great confidence
in your ability
to meet the challenges
that lie ahead.
For in this special
and auspicious day,
you our graduate students and
our undergraduates seniors,
are now and shall be forever
into the future Princeton
University's great
class of 2015.
Congratulations,
and best wishes.